[Musique]
est ce que vous vous êtes déjà demandé
quand vous étiez petit vraiment petit
parce que je sais que je ne suis pas
très fin quand vous étiez vraiment très
jeune
pourquoi est-ce que vous alliez jouer
avec un objet ou un autre pourquoi
est-ce que vous restiez chez vous ou est
ce que vous essayez de sortir dehors le
plus souvent possible
et bien moi voyez vous je ne me suis
jamais posé cette question parce que
c'était évident c'était tout à fait
normal
j'ai essayé de tout vendre à tout le
monde non vraiment j'ai essayé de
prendre certaines choses et de me dire
lui pourrait payer pour l'avoir alors de
la simple ficelle que je récupère est
par terre après un déménagement et que
j'ai essayé de revendre voisins très
compliqué quand on vient d'emménager
d'expliquer que son fils essaye de
revendre des ficelles aux voisins ou
encore le fait que je montais carrément
au village de suite chez moi en corse
attire virginie pour aller ramasser des
noisettes et j'essayais de les revendre
encore une fois aux voisins c'était mon
premier marché eh bien j'ai toute ma vie
du moins toute mon enfance trouver des
projets et essayer d'apporter de la
valeur au tout début je jouais beaucoup
un jeu vidéo qui s'appelle world of
warcraft vous en avez sûrement déjà
entendu parler dans ce jeu vidéo on a
des armures et on pouvait payer et
dépenser de l'argent réel contre des
avantages et des meilleurs armure dans
ce jeu alors évidemment je ne savais pas
multiplier l'argent réel sinon je leur
ai claqué des doigts sans jamais
m'arrêter
par contre je savais multiplier en
trichant les armures dans ce jeu vidéo
alors très rapidement j'ai commencé à le
faire et je revendais aux joueurs moins
cher que le serveur world of warcraft
lui même les armures ça a duré quelques
jours avant que je me fasse virer
ensuite je me suis dit bon ben il faut
en retenir la leçon
je vais monter mon propre serveur comme
ça je le pourrais vendre à mes joueurs
il y aura plus de problème mais j'ai pas
réussi à le revendre mon serveur était
jeune et quand j'allais voir les joueurs
et je leur disais pourquoi vous
n'achetez pas ces armures pour que vous
n'achetez pas je peux vous proposer des
choses extraordinaires
ils font oui mais ton serveur il existe
depuis quelques minutes
ton serveur on sait pas s'il va
continuer demain et on n'a pas confiance
est là j'avais compris la confiance si
on crée de la confiance on a un bon lien
et on pourra vendre comme mon serveur a
pris de l'âge qu'il a pris de
l'ancienneté
les joueurs ont commencé à dépenser de
l'argent pour être mieux loti dans le
jeu
par la suite j'ai continué à
m'intéresser à la valeur sur internet
et là j'ai découvert les sites de paris
sportifs j'avais à peu près 15 ans aucun
problème pour m'inscrire sur un jeu
d'argent puisque j'ai utilisé l'identité
de mes parents à l'époque et j'avais
parié au nom de ma maman et je me suis
dit mais comment est ce qu'ils font les
sites de paris sportifs
ils ont tous les scores de tous les
matchs de foot de la planète en temps
réel ils ont quand même pas un employé
dans chaque stade c'est pas possible eh
bien je me suis rendu compte que je
pouvais avoir cette information avant
eux et donc je prenais des positions sur
les paris sportifs jeux parier sur le
score exact du match alors qu'il avait
déjà eu lieu
alors autant vous dire que j'ai été très
souvent très proche du score j'ai volé
plusieurs centaines de milliers d'euros
un site de paris sportifs français qui
m'a tout de suite interdit l'accès et
récupérer tous les fonds évidemment tout
de suite après mes parents me remettre
les pieds sur terre
maintenant tu arrêtes tes bêtises
j'arrive au lycée un petit peu plus
grands les idées un petit peu mieux fait
et je me dis maintenant qu'est ce qu'on
va pouvoir vendre et donc bien
évidemment idiot 15 16 ans je pose des
questions à mes camarades qu'est ce que
vous seriez prêt à acheter puis en
rigolant des idées toutes plus étranges
les unes que les autres et là j'avais
trouvé un bon produit quelque chose qui
allait se vendre quelque chose que tout
le monde voulait essayer on commence à
être un petit peu jeune par contre
fallait pas se faire attraper la falaise
discrets alors au début j'en vendais à
mes contacts de confiance encore une
fois au début j'en vendais à mes amis
qui après quand j'avais plus de marché
j'avais plus de clients j'ai demandé à
mes amis de me présenter leurs amis
augmentation du cercle de connaissances
augmentation des horizons et du marché
sauf qu'à un moment les amis de vos amis
non plus d'amis non plus ou sinon ça
devient très très compliqué alors du
coup j'ai été voir un peu ta - qui était
sacrément intelligent et m'a dit mais
owen les surveillants les pions tout le
monde a confiance en eux et le premier
pion que j'ai été voir il a dit alors
c'est vrai les pions pourrait revendre
pour toi mais fait mieux
les professeurs pourraient revendre pour
toi et là j'avais un réseau de
distribution sans faille ont touché
l'intégralité du lycée on était capable
de vendre à n'importe qui
très rapidement ça s'est arrêté
l'administration s'en est rendu compte
un petit peu violent mais globalement ça
s'est bien fini
par contre vous n'imaginerait pas jamais
dans votre vie vous ne pourrez pas
compris
ce qu'il a ressenti à ce moment là mais
vous n'imaginez pas la tête de mon père
quand il a découvert caché derrière sa
moto dans le garage 250 vaches en
plastique
ça a été compliqué ouais ils ont mis un
moment aussi à s'en remettre
si je vous raconte toutes ces petites
histoires c'est pour une seule et simple
raison
j'ai fait des bêtises quand j'étais
gosse mais je me suis très vite rendu
compte que malgré ces marchés plutôt
différents les uns des autres
il y avait un point commun le point
commun était toujours le même
ça tournait autour de la confiance le
serveur les joueurs devaient avoir
confiance aux serveurs pour dépenser de
l'argent réel contre des avantages
virtuel le site de paris sportifs
j'arrivais à le doubler parce qu'il
pensait avoir confiance en une
information qui recevait le score exact
alors que je l'avais eu avant lui c'est
comme ça que j'ai pu le doubler
et encore une fois quand on est jeune et
qu'on vend ce genre de produit très
délicat d'ailleurs tout le monde venait
et m'ont acheté en disant c'est pour un
ami à moi j'ai bien sûr eh bien on
devait avoir confiance parce qu'on a
peur que ce genre de choses se sachent
et j'ai vite compris que ce qui
m'attirait quel que soit le business
qu'est ce que soit le projet quelle que
soit la valeur c'était le lien de
confiance que je pouvais créer avec mon
client
j'arrive dans une école de commerce
lilloise 18 ans mes parents m'ont dit
cette fois si tu recommences pas mais je
me lance sur internet et je cherche
toujours des nouvelles idées et là je
tombe sur une technologie qui s'appelle
la blocs chaîne j'en ai entendu parler
ça venait du bitcoin son prix avaient
explosé
d'ailleurs la plupart d'entre vous qui
connaissent ce mot l'ont sûrement déjà
entendu parce que son prix vient
d'exploser
je m'intéresse à la blocs chaîne de
l'argent virtuel
son prix exploser des gens deviennent
riches il manquait pas beaucoup
d'éléments pour que je sois intéressé je
vais sur internet tout de suite blocs
chaîne je tape sur google et là la
première ligne qui vous donne vraiment
envie d'aller plus loin et de découvrir
la technologie
c'est un registre distribué de stockage
peer-to-peer jeu regrettait presque mes
anciennes idées j'ai continué à chercher
et là j'ai compris d'où ça vient en 2008
il ya eu une grosse crise bancaire les
banques avaient abusé et avait perdu de
l'argent
les gouvernements avaient dû renflouer
les banques avec l'argent du
contribuable
vous il ya quelqu'un qui s'est dit mais
qu'est ce qui se passe si demain je peux
plus avoir confiance parce que tout
repose sur la confiance
qu'est ce qui se passe si demain quand
j'ouvre l'eau de mon robinet je me
demande si à l'empoisonner qu'est ce qui
se passe c'est quand le feu passe au
vert
j'ose pas avancer parce que je me dis
peut-être que notre île est pas passé au
rouge on va faire un accident tout
repose sur la confiance
qu'est ce qui se passe si demain je n'ai
plus confiance en sa ce petit bout de
papier c'est un bout de papier mais non
c'est un bout de papier rempli de
confiance et c'est pour ça qu'on regarde
et c'est pour ça qu'on fait attention à
ce petit bout de papier parce qu'on a
confiance en lui et bien cette personne
en 2008 elle avait plus confiance aux
banques elles n'avaient plus confiance
au gouvernement et elle s'est posé une
question qu'est ce qui se passe ici tout
s'effondre comment je fais comment je
fais pour prouver que c'est ma maison
comment je fais pour garder mon argent
si je veut dépenser beaucoup d'argent
aujourd'hui mon gouvernement peu gelé
mais qu'ont ils peuvent me dire non
personne ne dira non c'est mon travail
c'est mon argent gelé mérité et ce
monsieur là il a créé la toute première
blocs chaîne le bitcoin alors pour
revenir sur ce mot un peu barbare
registre décentralisée donc un espace de
stockage
imaginez plutôt un livre une clé usb
n'importe quoi dans lequel on peut
stocker des choses et à côté de ça en
parallèle peer to peer
c'est pas barbare ça veut dire de
particulier à particulier
si je prends la bouteille que la donne à
l'un d'entre vous on peut dire que c'est
une transaction peer to peer
je n'ai pas donné à une banque qui va
venir vous la donner c'était direct
entre nous et maintenant je vais essayer
de vous expliquer comment fonctionne la
blocs chaîne une technologie pourtant
bien complexe imaginez un livre géant
juste ici à ma gauche
oui c'est la droite pour vous juste là
et on écrit tout ce qui se passe dans ce
livre géant on écrit ma position
on écrit comment je suis habillé on
écrit tous les mots que j'utilise mon
écrit également où vous êtes et tout ce
qui se passe par ordre chronologique
quand une page est plein on passe à la
page suivante
si je donne quelque chose à l'un d'entre
vous on va écrire au yen à donner à tel
moment tels objets à telle personne
rien que comme ça vous venez de
comprendre comment on peut échanger des
choses avec un espace de stockage
c'est un simple livre mais si on se met
tous d'accord pour lui faire confiance
et qu'il ya quelqu'un qui en retard très
en retard et qui vient s'asseoir hôtel
maintenant en lisant ce livre depuis la
toute première page il va pouvoir
comprendre qu'est ce qui s'est passé qui
a dit quoi
ou est-ce qu'on en ait et
surtout cette bouteille d'eau qui est là
par terre qui est ce qui l'a mis là et à
qui elle appartient et c'est comme ça
qu'avec un simple livre avec un simple
espace de stockage on peut échanger de
la valeur si dans la première page
j'explique qu'il y aura que deux
personnages dans ce livre monsieur à et
monsieur b qui ont tous les deux sens
bitcoin est que dans la première page
monsieur add-on 50 bitcoin à monsieur b
on n'a même pas besoin de calculer les
comptes on sait qu'ils avaient l'argent
au début
quelles transactions ont été faites on
sait que monsieur b en a 150 et que
monsieur à on a 50
c'est comme ça que ça fonctionne la
blocs chaîne c'est comme ça que ça
fonctionne le bitcoin et c'est pas un
livre qui relie des pages entre elles
ces pages ce sont des blocs dans
laquelle on met les informations et le
livre qui relie tous les blocs c'est une
chaîne voilà pourquoi ça s'appelle la
blocs chaîne et voilà pourquoi ça permet
aux gens d'échanger des choses il ya
plusieurs exemples de la blocs chaîne
alors on voit beaucoup le bitcoin à la
base c'était pour être décentralisé
ce livre là est mis à jour par des
milliers et des milliers de personnes un
gouvernement ne peut pas l'arrêter
personne ne peut fermer ce livre un pays
non plus une monnaie non plus un
dictateur non plus la blocs chaîne ça ne
s'arrête pas et la bloque chaîne ça ne
sert pas qu'à échanger de l'argent
c'était la preuve est évidemment l'être
humain a été très bon avec ça mais on
peut faire plein d'autres choses
il y à des assurances en france vous
êtes peut-être même assuré de cette
assurance qui rembourse 50 % du prix de
votre avion s'il arrive en retard
alors bon s'il arrive en retard vous
devez contacter votre assurance
l'assurance va contacter l'aéroport
vérifier que vous étiez sur le vol c'est
très compliqué c'est très long quatre à
huit semaines et ça demande énormément
de temps à l'aéroport à l'assurance et à
vous avec une blocs chaîne qui a été
créée par cette assurance
ils ont doté une bonne chaîne donc ce
livre d'une intelligence on appelle ça
un smart contracte et la bloque chaîne
elle sait tous les avions de la planète
où ils sont et lesquelles sont en retard
tout de suite quand un avion est en
retard elle va vérifier
est ce que mon client qui est chez moi
était sur cet avion
si elle voit que le client était sur cet
avion elle vérifie est ce que le client
avait souscrit à cette assurance
oui est-ce que j'ai bien vérifié son
identité oui là blocs chaîne envoie
l'ordre à l'assurance de payer le client
tout de suite vous n'êtes même pas
encore montés dans l'avion qui en retard
la blocs chaîne de cette assurance vous
à rembourser
encore un autre exemple vous avez
peut-être des panneaux solaires sur le
toit de votre maison
eh bien vous le savez pas mais c'est
même valable en moselle vous pouvez
connecter votre panneau solaire à la
blocs chaîne solar coyne une autre
crypto monnaie dès que vous allez généré
1 kilowatts d'énergie renouvelable vous
allez recevoir un seul arkane et avec ce
seul art quand ils vous pouvez faire
plein de choses soit l'échanger contre
de l'argent vous générez l'énergie
renouvelable vous êtes récompensés soit
tout simplement les voir une entreprise
qui vend l'électricité et qui accepte et
y en a une en moselle par exemple et
payer plus d'électricité avec votre sol
arkane soit allé voir votre voisin et
lui dire ok maintenant toi tu génères
beaucoup plus d'énergie que moi j'ai
plus envie d'en acheter à telle personne
je vais acheter ton énergie à toi et on
retrouve le dialogue peer to peer
on retrouve ce contact on n'a plus
besoin d'une entité d'un tiers qui va
nous dire qu'est ce qu'est la confiance
ou pas
c'est ça la bonne chaîne c'est pas un
outil sur mesure pour régler un problème
sur mesure c'est une boîte à outils avec
de la pâte à modeler à l'intérieur et on
peut faire la solution on peut créer la
solution qu'on veut aux problèmes qu'on
veut je vous dis pas que tu dois changer
et que la centralisation c'est pas bien
qu'on doit faire tomber les banques
c'est pas ça qui est en train de vous
dire mais ce que je suis en train de
vous dire c'est qu'un jour si on ne sait
plus comment faire si on n'a plus de
solution
si tout se ferment devant nous ce sera
peut-être la dernière solution
là où le lab look chaîne a été pour moi
un vrai bon c'était la technologie qui
incarnait la confiance j'avais tourné
autour toute ma vie c'était une
technologie informatique de mon époque
qui allait être une révolution sans
doute plus grande qu internet et s'était
basée sur la confiance
l'essence même de tout ce qui m'animait
de ce qui me donnait cette énergie ce
qui me donnait envie d'aller encore plus
vite et d'y aller encore plus fort pour
moi ça a été un bon ça a été un
démarrage mais ce que j'essaye vraiment
de vous dire ce soir est ce que
j'aimerais vous partager comme message
c'est que si d'un coup on perd la
confiance en notre monnaie et que ce
billet n'est plus qu'un bout de papier
si un jour notre gouvernement ne nous
répondent plus ou si une guerre éclate
si un jour on a plus aucun dialogue ne
peut plus prouvé que c'est notre maison
tout se ferment devant nous et bien à ce
moment là et je vous le garantis la
blocs chaîne
ce sera notre rebond collectif merci
[Applaudissements]